this is more of a of a request than a
video but i've been contacted by a news
organization that's doing a a piece on
the khan academy and they've asked me if
i could find people who live in
new delhi
new delhi
bangkok
bangkok
dubai
or hong kong and i think the reason why
they asked for these cities is because
they have
bureaus in those cities and they want to
see how it's being used on in all parts
of the planet so if you are a khan
academy user and you've benefited from
the site and are willing to have some
people show up with cameras at your
house to see how you use it and
interview you
interview you
send me an email at sal
khan academy
con
academy
dot org and in your email tell me who
you are how old you are what context
you're using the khan academy in and how
it might have been useful doesn't have
to be anything a long and flowery and
i'll send those emails i'll forward them
over to the international news
organization that approached me and they
may or may not contact you and you need
to get this to me as soon as possible
they just told me about this today
they're going to do the piece no matter
what but they would like to include some
footage from some of y'all all over the
world i need the deadline is
i'll make it the 5th of of january or
essentially
january 5th 2010 which is tomorrow
tuesday a lot of y'all are probably
asleep as i uh put this video out so
i'll check my email uh in the morning on
january 5th to see if any of y'all have
responded because they told me that they
want to have this piece done by
wednesday so if you email me by tomorrow
morning they might come over uh fairly
fairly quickly so email me uh khan
academy.org tell me which of these
cities you live in tell me the context
and who you are of how i use the khan
academy and maybe we'll get you on tv